yeah man what do you think do you think
you think the Civil War Boogaloo chaos
no rights in the streets you know I
don't think so
I think this because they're gonna
they're gonna finally meet the armed
Americans that are like you're not
coming to our town waiting you come into
my house I'm gonna kill you straight up
they're gonna hit hit that wall and then
all of a sudden they're gonna start
seeing others getting killed they're
like oh whoa but dude we were just
playing a game no I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about the we're talking
about them the army MP active-duty who
killed a cop and said you know what and
then he wrote like in blood Boogaloo or
something some ridiculous thing yeah and
and then and then the the other two guys
who drove up to New York with a bunch of
weapons and like these people are saying
like we're here to make this happen or
whatever and these are lefty guys like
they're the ones posting in support of
black lives matter and maybe they're not
really lefty maybe they're just you know
they want some kind of revolution or
something yeah but they're a couple guys
here and they're active duty I don't I
don't see happening man so you've got
these generals coming out and defying
the president now and standing opposed
to him so we had what did we have Philly
no we had no really really just said I
shouldn't have gone with him to the
church that's all he said and we had
three I think three former Joint Chiefs
president yeah that he would that he was
a Nazi and that he was a tyrant and that
he was abusing the rule of law and
things like that counting heads but how
how it doesn't they were a huge thing up
and they gave a huge and then they all
started chiming in and yeah they wrote a
ton of stuff about it and K and it
doesn't it that the issue isn't so much
whether or not I guess now they're
saying that could be recalled to active
duty and then prosecute it or something
okay the issue isn't so much whether or
not they're justified in saying it but
counting head started a long time ago
man they they prosecute or they they
fired the the Navy captain who said hey
our ship is is respected with kovat
we're sick well yeah came down on him
yeah but the argument for that is he
basically revealed a major secret oh
yeah uh-huh yeah that's that's you know
a lot of five to six percent of our you
know
yes but and that makes us as Americans
seem weak right right he came out and
said isn't that the reason he got in
trouble you got in trouble for it I was
not any different than these guys that
are supposedly part of the military
saying that kind of stuff
what do you mean how does that not make
America look weak that they're coming
out and saying Trump is bad all that
stuff well I mean they're they're not
like a media company that just is is
saying it and everyone's used to it it's
like actually military members that are
saying it right dad yeah it is exactly
so that's the point I'm making what
happens if Trump wins mm-hmm and these
people have already announced they stand
against him and then what happens when
Bill Barr start saying here's the
indictments and he actually names some
people and then the left claims Trump
stole the election and cheated or
something you have you already have you
know rights across the country you have
this weird scenario where the media and
the establishment is simultaneously
right now you've got the Chas where
people are all sitting around each other
watching movies and what is CNN say oh
it's peaceful there's no anti if I hear
the New York Times says they've
liberated the streets then Trump
announces I want to have a rally and
they say he's violating CDC guidelines
they're burning their digitally burning
books I'm so sick of these the Democrats
double standards man that it all I see
is them have them trying to apply rules
saying whoa whoa if Trump breaks these
rules we're gonna change it and and he's
bad what is all I'm seeing what do you
think happens if Trump wins and then the
Democrats file a suit in the in the
courts it goes to the Supreme Court
arguing that the suppression of mail and
voting was Trump rigging the election
and the Supreme Court sides of the
Democrats and kicks Trump out do you
think people in America are gonna be
like well they're burning books they're
banning movies they're banning art and
that's okay I don't think the American
the general like public thinks that and
that's actually what's happening right
now but it's it's these little slower
they're they're not on Twitter they're
not on that they're in their little
bubbles you know rooting for Trump just
talking to their friends the a I'm gonna
vote for Trump and in the four years
that rub has been president all this has
gotten worse yeah because they they hate
him but was people who are sitting in
their homes not speaking up saying yeah
yeah I'm gonna go vote for Trump okay
and then Trump gets elected and four
years later everything's
are they just gonna go vote for Trump
again then it gets worse another four
years I have no idea that's that that's
the point I don't know when you combine
all these things together it looks like
the powder keg is is popping off yeah
like I don't you know I've seen we've
already seen Boogaloo boys I don't even
know that's a real thing but people like
there's three dudes who got caught with
a bunch of weapons recently and they're
their only objective it was not
necessarily political it was just to
spark things and you had two guys from
Ohio who went to New York got caught
then you had the active-duty MP who went
off and and you know killed the deputy
yet the van pull up in Oakland and shoot
the cop yeah like we're all of these
things are happening weren't those
lawyers also handing out Molotov
cocktails supposedly yes they're saying
they're handing out maltose yeah so when
you see lawyers and regular people
jumping to the front lines anybody
anybody can be brought past the edge
yeah to go crazy anybody yeah but just
because there is a lawyer that went
crazy doesn't mean all lawyers are gonna
go crazy said that yeah no I'm not I'm
not saying anyone did say it I'm just
making a point
it's like just because we're seeing it
happen that there's military people that
are that killed a cop it's like okay
that's happened in the past too you know
you know probably all it'll probably
happen again sure it's it's one thing
when Dorner you know writes a manifesto
and says here's why I'm doing this right
and it's isolated it's another thing
when you have in Oakland st. Louis Las
Vegas Minneapolis these ambushes ambush
attacks on cops the Vegas copying put in
critical condition combined with a bunch
of people showing up in seizing
territory to what extent you want to
call it seizing then you have
Minneapolis going to abolish their
police while books are being banned
movies are being banned and art is being
banned these are all things that we were
told together was the sign of the rise
of fascism yep that's true so if so so I
can only assume that if the left thinks
they're the good guys and they're
literally burning and banning books and
banning art they're not who's the last
people to do that well I mean probably
Venezuela
yeah sure yeah whatever comm unit
China's doing it now yeah you know
speaking of China I have a feeling
they're behind a lot of this who has the
most to gain with us going under them
they we've found they were bringing in
viruses literally paying paying
professors now we're finding out and
tifo was going into schools to recruit
and it's like hmm I have a feeling we're
gonna go to war with China before at
boogalou happens here in the States or
yeah that's what I think well that's why
I said the longshot prediction I had
before was that before anything reaches
critical mass there'll be some kind of
false flag or I shouldn't call it a
false flag but some kind of attack on us
yeah that force of the country to unite
against a common enemy I don't think
it's actually hard to say because I
think this goes all the way the top look
if you have Donald Trump accusing Barack
Obama okay of trying to sabotage his
presidency then you clearly have at the
highest levels of government a split
well sure enough there's this thing I
don't know if you've heard called Obama
gate that's going on it's going on right
now yep a bunch of officials right but
no one's talking about it mainstream
media is not talking about it it's like
what's going on so what's going on with
that this is the point even if even if
you know war was trying to broke out and
why would any of these high-ranking
elite factions side with each other so
what everyone in America is just gonna
be like let's just let China win more
fine whatever no we're not gonna fight
you'll probably get the commies saying
China helped us and what percentage of
kata would the commies be eight percent
maybe okay the progressive far left that
believe in all this weird critical race
stuff yeah and then China says we're
going to help you get rid of this person
or whatever but then you also look at
the high-ranking government officials
the people at universities who have
their you know the tendrils that China
has reached and corrupted so I can't
tell you you know who would accept or
wouldn't but what I can say is even if
we have a common enemy if the if it goes
all over the top the past president and
the current president you know are
accusing each other and and and and you
know facing a rift between each other
yeah
there's what happens where they finally
say okay you know we're good now let's
go fight China that's that's something
I've been saying it's like you're not
even allowed to to change your opinion
you can't even someone you can't even
have a debate it feels like they you
have to maintain whatever side you're on
to the death instead of right and that's
a that's an issue we gotta let that go
we got to be able to know you're wrong
what are you talking about how many are
you you're gonna agree with people
banning books in art absolutely not
right so they're gonna come to you and
say no I'm not gonna side with you
unless we ban your hate speech and
you're gonna say no I don't care if
people talk hate against me and that's
an that's something we need to we have
to have thicker skin man freedom is
right you can say what you want I don't
care what you say who are you to even
speak they don't agree with you direct
yeah but well I don't agree with them
exactly so where'd you ever unite with
them with the 8% of the population the
ad links the crazy stuff and one of
burned books no I wouldn't agree with
and they're the act and they're the
active left-wing in this country
according to the hidden tribes you've
got conservatives and progressive
activists that are active and everyone
in between is not paying attention so
maybe this sparks will wake up in
liberals who become moderate or become
active and say I'm not gonna stand for
this either but I'll tell you what man
when I talked to my liberal friends and
their actual liberals are not
progressives okay they say I mean what's
wrong with banning hate speech and I'm
like you actually agree with people who
are burning books like Amazon is
literally but I mean Amazon doesn't have
to sell anything they don't want to and
there it is
they don't care they're not gonna get
involved and the active people on the
other side are literally dude it's not
even about the progressive activists
it's about all of our mainstream
institutions now collectively just
burning everything yeah that's crazy I
know and I'm not gonna stand for it I
mean either I think Oh ridiculous yep
and I think it's it's horrifying
and everything that is our country and
everything that even is the West in the
in the UK like the United Kingdom and in
Europe always stood for you know against
this stuff we mocked and and ridiculed
and condemned book burning yeah we wrote
books about how bad it was to burn books
and now
mainstream culture in our country is
actively doing it and it's getting worse
you know you have reasoning my point
proving my point these people that are
so far these 8% you're talking about
they're so crazy and int Amazon that
they're correct they Google they need to
borrow these books Twitter whatever it
is whatever it is they aren't even there
so vicious in their thought process they
can't come away from it
because it's it's part of their pride
now it's part of their their emotional
trigger system they can't they can't
relinquish it and that is what I'm
talking about that's the problem right
and and there's people all over the
place that feel the same way it's like
no no I'm right you're wrong no
exceptions I don't care I'll hate you
because of it and it's like what is
wrong with people you have to be able to
see the the entire situation and and
accept that you can change and it's this
hated thing it's this simple
google has told me I can't say a name
Senator Rand Paul was has video removed
from YouTube for saying a name our
government right was challenging the
impeachment of the President and Google
a major company where the most powerful
companies on the planet deleted that
video okay these people aren't just a
small faction of nobodies they're
extremely powerful and yet you're here
not saying his name so you won't get
banned right so it's you're going along
with the - right I have to I have to
choose the compromise can I say the name
or not and actually have this
conversation to make sure people know
what's going on or do I just burn it all
down but I'll tell you what doesn't what
won't happen is when it comes down to an
actual conflict when you know come
November if they say Trump cheated in
Trump says no they cheated and
everyone's fighting will you stand side
by side with the people who want to burn
books and if they can't really no and if
they came to you said listen China's a
bigger threat we need to come together
just let us burn some books no no books
that's what I said earlier didn't I the
divided States that's why I'm saying he
that happened all those divided States
of America man and that's the point I'm
making there is no circumstance where
you can reconcile this divide the Free
Press net is the name of their
organization and they advocate for
censorship if if our nonprofits
that are supposed to fight for the free
press support censorship and want to
shut down the Free Press we are we are
beyond a point where this bridge this
divide can be mended I mean you said it
yourself if the trucker's stopped going
to the cities and and the blue states
say or the blue cities all the Democrat
we're on everything go you know what
whatever we're gonna do what we want and
all the red states slash farmers and and
like rural like Americans that are
living in the country go fine do you do
you we're gonna keep our food we're not
gonna help you we're gonna split off
from you the trucker's aren't gonna go
to these cities they're gonna just it's
it's gonna be a complete structural
change and all those people that you're
talking about that that are the the
loudest son Twitter I guess the loudest
in in their 8 to 8 percent they're gonna
they're gonna starve they're gonna
starve themselves out or a lot of the
trucker's just say hey man I don't want
to be involved just tell me what I got
to do to get my paycheck man you think
that they're these truckers are gonna
drive into a police 'less zone where
there's a warlords fighting over who's
gonna be in control week next week it
might be it'd still be razz but the
following week it might be the next the
next warlord that killed razza took a
spot if it gets that bad I know who
knows I don't know they're not it's a
lawless place they supposedly stole
something and they surround and they
surrounded him with bats saying what
would you took it huh why'd you take it
why'd you run it's like what they don't
know a thing so it's a lawless place
right so that I would truckers go in
there so so what do you think these far
leftists who are armed are gonna do once
the food stops do you think they'll just
die they're gonna go out to the armed
Americans and get killed that's what I
said earlier they're gonna be like you
know what let's go get the food too from
the farmers and the farmers are like
come on itis yeah maybe come on out yeah
and they're gonna rally up all of their
towns folk that all know each other's
names even the police officers are like
yeah yeah Jimmy I got you I'll come help
protect your farm for sure this is a
civil war yeah if this leads if it keeps
going and they don't stop chaz and
people steep flock into chas and it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger in seattle
and it will be blue versus red and then
what happens if at that that moment
China attacks good luck yeah for us
forever
everybody yeah that's that's the biggest
fear we should have as we're facing
serious conflict from China the best
time to attack would be when our cities
our police lists
yes heading up autonomous zones yeah and
then so give it six months when this
starts spreading if Trump goes in with
the military to Chad's I think it'll
make it way worse because it'll it'll
it'll light people up and there's
nothing you can do about it there listen
man I here I asked I asked my followers
I mean granted I I don't you know I'm a
small little corner in the Twitterverse
you know III asked went when he said you
know the government in Washington needs
to take take care of this and and end it
now
and he was posting Law & Order Law &
Order I'm like who wants him to go take
take control I would say 95% of the
responses were like yes he needs to take
control because this is ridiculous and
then you know it's gonna happen they're
gonna blame it on him and now how dare
he do this
how dare he overstep his bounds in that
in cities across this for him to do this
for months now
oh man you how dare you close down our
borders because of coronavirus how dare
you do it you xenophobe oh man a month
later I would have closed them first
I would have closed them a week before
he did it and it's just like god it's
everything anything if they can pin it
on him they do it's insane the hope is
so sick of it the hope is that your
perception of the divide right is
correct so when you look at the polls
it's actually fairly even and maybe the
polls are wrong yeah maybe the Trump
supporters are keeping their mouths shut
because they don't want to lose their
jobs to be attacked by the mob
I honestly I've seen people say that
like I've noticed like I can't even talk
to my family because I'm a trump
supporter and they hate me now and why
didn't that change ever the first time
they voted for Trump well I did it only
because the Democrats immediately Russia
gate it once out Russia gate ended in
but why would one day they voted for
Trump in secret Trump won now it's now
is it is a finally okay to say that you
know we are part of that silent majority
he won that proved us
right no they still remained quiet they
said nothing yeah because the Democrats
went crazy
into this hole no it Russia Russia
Russia rosenau and it's like turns out
that was all I turns out and it seems
like that's something that the Obama
administration was spinning but it's not
changed what was the rhetoric has only
escalated
now they're saying Trump will need to be
removed from the White House by the
military as a Joe Biden just said yeah
Joe Biden said so what happens if Trump
wins legitimately wins
mm-hm and all the DeMars have Democrats
have to do is say we have proof he
cheated like Adam Schiff lied about the
evidence he had so how would I believe
why would I believe anything that they
say you wouldn't but a lot of people do
a lot of people do sixty-five million
people voted for Hillary Clinton okay
Trump's base is bigger based on certain
polls you know from like last August New
York Times well once Biden picks Hillary
is his running mate its height of over
form maybe but they're not they're not
it's gonna happen they're not see it
they're not running Biden to run Biden
they're running against Trump yeah and
they're they're not running Biden to run
bite and they're running Biden to be the
placeholder after Oh everybody doesn't
get super mad let me ask you let me
switch them out with whoever they pick
after everything that's happened over
the past four years from Russia gate
Ukraine gate impeachment all is the lies
about Kovan okay do you think they'd be
willing to cheat in the election
Democrats yeah yes and what if they do
definitely and what if they do what
where they cheat to win yeah like
literally burn ballots and stuff ballots
and cheap what can I do Tim what I don't
know what I'd be able to do I don't know
the only thing I can think of is getting
into government myself do I want to do
that if they're cheating no way do I
have any interest no I have zero
interest but this is this is every
single time I ask myself what is the
best way to figure out how to like
handle this because I'm looking at the
government what is the government old
people yep all old people yep that are
out of touch they don't get it they all
think they know the answers they've had
a lifetime of thinking that and now all
of them are fighting and bickering
amongst each stuff is like yeah we need
we need younger people in government and
you know the problem is the answer yeah
the problem is for you and me what's
that we have no political party that's
true none
yeah I'm not a Democrat and I'm not a
republic exactly you would have been a
Democrat six seven years ago
maybe I thought I was four look you look
at the polls and they flip with the far
left taking over now and now what do
they say burn books ban speech ban art
ridiculous not liberal and the
old-school Democrat said well whatever
gets his power and Nancy Pelosi is on
her way out she bends the need of these
people because she knows she is the
exact opposite of the Greek proverb that
a society grows great when people plant
trees in in whose shade they know they
will never sit you know Nancy Pelosi
Chuck Schumer they're the opposite of
that saying absolutely they are burning
it all down around them so they can have
a little tiny morsel of power at 80
years old
yep it's ridiculous I mean they've been
in government for 40 50 years and in
everything's Trump's fault yep he's been
in power for three and a half years yeah
so no no it's all Trump's fault it's not
some system makes issue with the way
things have been run for a long time
it's like come on yes it is yeah that's
exactly what it is there are there's
probably a potential that if you ran as
a moderate Republican in a blue area
okay you might win the problem is no no
no I would win I don't know I don't
think so no in a d-plus 30 district yep
I would he thinks I'm a d-plus 30
definitely you think so I'm confident I
guess that I guess people want someone
that has at least some semblance of an
idea and and you know what I have you
ever have you ever watched a documentary
about Bobby Kennedy no man what a boss
that dude was awesome and it's no
surprise that he got shot and killed
before he become president I believe it
but he had he went to the rural areas
and and the poor areas and and every
Aryan was like man we can fix this we
have to fix this we have to figure out a
way to like help everybody and it's like
that's what we need
I know I'm not a Democrat no I'm not a
Republican but I I I love people and I
want everyone to be happy I want
everyone to feel privileged pro-life or
pro-choice I'm pro-choice then you would
not win in a Republican district okay
and you would not win
and so right now the left has become
overtly pro-abortion
not even pro-choice it's funny because
when you mention that mm-hmm they say
you're lying it's not true we're
pro-choice but it's like when I show my
friends the video from Virginia okay
where Ralph Northam talks about
delivering the baby and then deciding
after the fact what to do with it
they're like whoa wait that really
happened believe they don't believe it
yeah so I'm pro-choice that's the
compromise but you've either got to be
like Michelle wolf who cuz the Netflix
and gos everybody gets an abortion you
get an abortion you get an abortion and
I'm like that's insane you know it is
psychotic so this is another thing you
know if you want to talk about it's like
I'll talk about it we got to figure out
why so many people are getting abortions
sure sure you know it's like there's
cases for it but it's like that's what I
that's what I want to talk about what is
the reason anything is happening why are
people getting cancer why is there poor
people why are why are cops killing
people why why are the things happening
that's what we need to fix let's stop
putting more medicine on stuff making us
live longer
let for sure let's figure out the reason
no I don't have all the answers no I'm
not gonna have you know ever every idea
I have you're gonna like but let's talk
about it
Pete Buddha judge a man gave a pretty
good response in my opinion when asked
if he was pro-life or pro-choice okay a
pro-life democrat said she's a pro-life
Democrat you know a lot of people in the
Democratic Party are pro-life rising Lee
and Buddha jej said well I'm personally
pro-choice you know I hope that he
basically said I know we might not agree
but I hope that you would choose me
trusting me to do the right thing when
it came to this decision-making process
I think that's the best thing someone
could say if they have a ideological
disagreement and he got roasted for it
by conservatives saying it was a
terrible or smoke was he supposed to say
if I'm pro-choice the best thing I can
do is say I'm willing have a
conversation maybe won't agree I really
don't know what else to do if you don't
like it please don't vote for me yeah
but he gets roasted for it so there
really are hard wedge issues that are
that that are problematic now maybe you
could run as a moderate Democrat but
what happened the moderate Democrats ran
in 2018 they said we're gonna do all the
normal things we're gonna fight for
normal issues we're gonna fight for it
for healthcare employment and then as
soon as they got voted in they were
holding the orange man bad ring and the
moderate voters said do it cast it into
the fire and they went yeah impeach
Trump yeah because the system is run by
a bunch of old people from old systems
the PISA moderates who won we're younger
yeah well we need everybody I can't I
can't just go up there and be like I'm
gonna be the one person that changes
things no no no we need a hundred of me
a thousand of me you know a different
people I'm not saying me personally I'm
saying all these younger generations
that are pissed about this get out there
though dude the millennial generation
uh-huh and Gen Z yeah our woke yes
that's true they they won't like you not
all of them yeah I disagree man I sure
they're out there yeah the woke
generation but they also are entitled
and feel like they are owed stuff you
think people are gonna vote for that
kind of attitude yes really think so I
think they'll vote for each other and
then it'll all fall apart okay that's
why I don't see an exit to this room
we're in I see you look at Chaz and with
all the problems they've experienced
they haven't learned a thing they're
just like dumping potted potting soil
onto a cardboard and then dropping a
potted plant on top of it it's like it's
like it's like watching idiocracy yeah
they think they're the smart ones while
they ban books and banned speech and
understand what's wrong with that the
Democratic the Democrats the top don't
care and they're laughing the whole time
haha any one of these people could shut
these people up they don't care they
like it so you have a you have a tiny
fraction of this country dictating
policy for for the most of it perhaps
perhaps what happens is come November
Trump wins and the Republicans win by
such an overwhelming majority like what
we saw in the UK that it shocks all of
these establishment institutions and
they stop doing this stuff but right now
they're the ones fueling it that would
be wonderful
but I don't I don't I don't believe
it'll happen I do Trump won the first
time and what do they do they ramped it
up it's been worse than ever and it's
only gotten worse and the best Trump
could ever do was say the FCC should
investigate and set some guidelines and
it's not gonna do anything maybe if the
Republicans win the house
they'll actually amend 232 say legal
speech is protected and that changes
everything but many people have said and
practice is true Trump will be the last
Republican president unless the
Republican Party becomes like the
Democrats are today
and then you end up with the woke party
and the you know kind of woke party and
then books are banned books are burned
so what happens to all those people who
say no to this I guess the big question
that we don't know is how big how many
people will support the book burnings I
have one about a lot of them I don't you
don't think so no I don't think so
I mean it's happening all around us
who's stopping them yeah they're sitting
in their little drum circles or whatever
you want to call it little little
circles of skyscraper skyscrapers in San
Francisco you mean yeah themselves
burning their own stuff
so mark Mark Zuckerberg sitting atop his
ivory tower in San Francisco is banning
Trump supporters left and right Jack
Dorsey Flags Donald Trump's tweets and
then glorifies violence himself you know
these these are billionaires these are
extremely powerful individuals who are
suppressing thought and ideas and
gloating about it and lying about it
these are not jump circles nothing will
stop them okay so what so it's like that
well as long as people still use their
platforms which they do you know maybe
we should get off Twitter maybe we need
to nationalize all of them Amazon but
they need someone like you to create a
new new Twitter what stop it's been
tried over and over and over again it's
been tried okay what they do is they're
they're drones in media immediately and
probably fake this themselves we'll find
one or two extremists you know and then
run a huge article expose about the new
neo-nazi website of course and then your
sponsors dry up and people panic and
they flee and they're the ones that that
seem like they're the Nazis and they're
burning books they're authoritarian they
were trying to divide everybody I refuse
to be divided I love all of my American
friends
love them love them all man even the
crazy ones Tim you refuse to be divided
yeah but if someone came and demanded
that you started burning a book I
wouldn't so you won't so you will stand
divided sure to the small percentage
that wants me to burn a book when it's
like that book even if it's hate speech
is showing me what hate speech is so I
guess what we don't we go right now
let's talk about it don't let's bring it
out there what we don't know right now
is how big the numbers really are but if
it's true that Joe Biden is polling as
well as he is while Joe Biden himself
calls for Facebook to censor speech
those numbers should be alarming to
everyone in this country well at least
they denied him at least they said no
sorry about him we're not gonna let
someone dictate what we do which is
rather interesting that they said that
face fate I think Facebook's aren't
hedging their bets that Trump is gonna
win and so at first they were censoring
everybody and then realized if the
Republicans take them take you know the
majority they're in serious trouble and
so they immediately backed off Twitter
however I think Twitter's convinced
Trump's gonna lose that's why they like
Twitter is the most egregious act out of
all of this and I think yeah I know I
think Jeff I think Jack Dorsey is
manipulative and duplicitous yeah I see
it
I've talked to the guy on more than one
occasion and he promises all of these he
whispers all these sweet nothings about
decentralization and all the good work
they're doing yeah and then what does he
do not that he personally writes his own
rules
yeah breaks his own rules fact checks
opinions what's what's uh rule for thee
but not me rules for thee but not for me
yeah and ridiculous you know I I think
all these companies are paying attention
to the riff that's growing and they're
the the the counting heads reason why
those Joint Chiefs of Staff and why the
general guy came out and stood against
Trump as their batting Trump will lose
well he's got my vote I guess we can
only wait and see man if who's right is
the media lying to us
yup so are the polls correct I have no
idea they could be wrong but res mucin
did a poll and they typically favor
Trump and found Trump's approval rating
was way down apparently Oh a n1 America
News was supposed to do a poll and
found that it was tied in Florida and so
they didn't end up running it it could
be that there really are a bunch of
people who are cheering for this stuff
look man I go I the propaganda is
everywhere it's one thing when you see
the support for black lives matter which
on the surface is totally fine the stuff
Dave Chappelle talked about was great
yeah but behind that are the extremists
who are using it to force people in this
country to burn books to ban movies to
ban art yes that's the nightmare
scenario it's messed up yeah it's really
funny there was a Jordan Peterson's book
was banned by a store in New Zealand
really but you could still buy mine
Kampf great yeah they wanna they want to
shut down modern opinions that could you
know keep people enlightened I guess I
mean it's it's clear they don't know
what they're doing though people are
they're tearing down statues of people
that that fought for the end of slavery
they're they're tear they're desecrating
statues of regiments of you know people
that fought for them that represented
true equality this is culture evolution
yeah it doesn't matter it's my stuff in
order to build a new world you must tear
down the old and they're doing it and
it's just happening they they're tearing
down statues and no one's stopping him
the police stand there and watch him do
it well look I gotta just say I hope I
have we got a lot of people here
watching it's like when when it does
happen you use your voice we have to be
the same people in the world that this
this is a platform you know I I want
everyone to know there's logical people
out there and I hope a lot of you are
it's like we got it we got to be vocal
we can't let these extremists
essentially I don't care what side
you're on if you're an extremist you're
blaming other people for for problems
you can probably work on yourself to fix
so we gotta help we gotta we gotta use
our voice we gotta we can't be silent
you gotta be I've got to speak up so
please I think I think this starts right
now
with people who have jobs yeah start
talking about this yeah if you were
gonna you know you know you weren't the
big challenges but these antiva people
these crazy far I'll just have no kids
they don't care they got nothing to lose
yeah they got
nothing and the people with families are
like I can't lose this job how am I
gonna feed my kids you know so they keep
bending the knee for the people who
don't have kids well I guess I'll tell
you this right now if you find yourself
in a position where you're more worried
about the immediate food for your kids
what future will be left for them if you
allow the loonatics to take over and do
all of this stuff thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you